you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live with
author pastor and evangelist Doug
Batchelor the phone number to join the
program and ask your questions is not
available this evening however if you
want to order any materials offered
during tonight's program you may call
our resource number anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact you've heard the
expression feeling blue well there are
some people who feel blue because they
are blue in the early 1960s a nurse
named Ruth Pendergrass got the shock of
her life when a woman walked into her
clinic in hazard Kentucky asking for a
blood test the woman's skin all over her
body was a deep indigo blue color who
thought she must be having a heart
attack but it turns out the lady was
part of the Fugate family from
troublesome Creek a remote settlement in
eastern Kentucky it all began in the
1800s with the children of Martin and
Elizabeth Fugate who both carried a rare
recessive gene this defective gene
caused four of their seven children to
be born blue even their nails were blue
and their lips were nearly purple this
unique condition medically known as okay
I'm gonna try this mess Elmo globe
anemia is caused from a missing enzyme
that helps supply the blood with oxygen
and other respects are perfectly healthy
but as you can imagine the family was
often embarrassed and experienced some
discrimination because of their odd skin
color this caused even greater social
isolation which it was exacerbating the
problem the fugate children married
close relatives creating more blue
people eventually Ruth Pendergrass
contacted dr. Madison Kalin from the
University of Kentucky fascinated by
their condition he performed some tests
and realized there was a simple antidote
for their blue skin problem ironically
the antidote was also blue
the first time he and nurse Pendergrass
injected it into two of the blue people
they changed to normal skin color in a
matter of minutes right before their
eyes the family was astonished
soon everybody struggling with this
condition had access to the simple
remedy and eventually the rare blue
people of Kentucky all but disappeared
did you know the Bible says that God has
an antidote to change the color of our
sins stay with his friends we're gonna
learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live you're listening to Bible
answers live honest answers to your
Bible questions this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
pray Lord that you'll be with this
program the Holy Spirit will take charge
of those who might be calling in with
questions and that the Holy Spirit will
guide in the answers coming from your
word we thank you and ask this in Jesus
name Amen you know I thought that was a
fascinating story I'd actually heard
before people that were called the Blue
Bloods of Europe and that was also
partly caused from this intermarriage
within some of the families of Europe
that they had that missing gene that
caused that problem
see if I can say it again Massimo globe
anemia and missing the enzyme that helps
the blood to absorb enough oxygen to
give it that red color and instead it
was blue called the blue bloods well
there was an antidote for that an enzyme
that was also blue and when they gave it
to the people they were healed from that
condition you know the Bible tells us
that God can change the color of our
sins you read in Isaiah chapter 8 verse
our chapter 1 verse 18 come now and let
us reason together says the Lord though
your sins be as scarlet they will be
white as snow and though they be red
like crimson they shall be as wool I
know it never makes sense logically to
think how can you make something that is
red white by washing it in blood how can
the blood of Jesus that Bible says that
the redeemed they've made their robes
white in the blood of the Lamb how does
that work
I remember the famous evangelist Billy
Sunday would say I don't understand how
the blood of Christ can wash away our
sin but I also don't know how a black
cow can eat green grass and make white
milk and yellow butter but it works
friends I can just tell you that the
gospel does work and that the blood of
Jesus can wash away your sin what can
wash away my sin nothing but the blood
of Jesus and there is power in the blood
maybe you'd like to know about that
power and you'd like to have your sins
washed away and be as the song says
lighter than snow and we have a special
offer we'd like to send you about how
you can take those steps to get a new
beginning and have your life and your
heart cleansed be a new creature it's
called three steps to heaven it is a
free book you can get it a couple of
ways one you can call the number I'm
going to give you now this is a
different number than the one that you
would call in with a Bible question this
is our resource line by the way there
are also chaplains that are at this
number if you want someone to pray with
here's that number for the book or for
prayer 800
eight three five six seven four seven of
course or free phone call 808 three five
six seven four seven and ask for the
book three steps to heaven the other way
you can get it is by simply going to the
amazing facts website under the free
book library you can download it read it
pass it on to a friend all for free so
help spread the word well with that
we're gonna go to our first Bible
question and I believe we're gonna be
talking with Charles who's calling from
New Port Richey Florida Charles you're
on the air with Bible answers live a
pastor Doug uh I'm actually a big fan
I've been watching your amazing facts
seminars yes well thank you for doing
that
you're very welcome I actually get a
blessing well how can I help you tonight
if my question is when Jesus returns
from the meal for the second coming
mm-hmm when the dead in Christ rise
first exactly is he gonna make two runs
like is he gonna go around the earth one
time and then gather all of those who
remain well you know you talk about the
sequence of how it will happen right if
yeah if you look in first Thessalonians
chapter four he says Paul is writing
there and he says I'll go to verse 15
for this we say to you by the word of
the Lord that you were alive and remain
until the coming of the Lord will by no
means precede that means go before those
who are asleep for the Lord Himself will
descend from heaven with a shout with a
voice of the Archangel and the Trump of
God and the dead in Christ will rise
first so there's your sequence then we
who are alive and remain will be caught
up together with them in the clouds now
the way I understand this I don't think
he's making two circles around the earth
I think what's happening is as the Lord
comes he probably will sweep around the
earth at least once as people are raised
and as the people are raised then
moments afterward we are transformed it
says in 1st Corinthians 15 and the
moment in the twinkling of an eye those
of us who are alive get these glorified
and we are caught up to meet them in the
air so first resurrection they're raised
we are caught up then to meet them in
the air as the Lord sweeps around the
circle of the earth and of course behind
him is left destruction Bible says that
all the tribes the earth will mourn when
they see him coming the lost and then
you know the cities are destroyed you
can read in Revelation 16 we go back to
heaven with him but I've actually got a
free lesson that I can send you that
talks about that if you'd like a copy of
that absolutely yeah if you you can go
to the website or you can call the
number and request it and it's a study
guide that's called are the dead really
dead it talks about the resurrection and
you know the other one is you can get
the study guide that's called the great
deliverance that talks about the second
coming or the ultimate deliverance talks
about the second coming of Jesus and
that also that lesson also talks about
the the saved being caught up I'm sorry
it's called rescue from above it's the
second coming of Jesus rescue from above
that talks about the resurrection and
the you would say the rapture of the
Saints we just don't believe it's a
secret rapture but hey I hope that helps
a little bit and we really appreciate
your calling Charles and you can
download those either at the website or
call the resource number 800 eight three
five six seven four seven and we thank
you for your call I also want to take a
minute and welcome those who might be
watching us on Facebook you can go to
the amazing facts Facebook page with a
Doug Batchelor Facebook page and you can
watch it for whatever it's worth you can
watch the radio program that sounds sort
of like a contradiction
Jerry is calling from Medford Oregon
Jerry you're on the air with Bible
answers live
you know pastor Doug lifted this is very
coincidental it's very similar to the to
the previous question all right
I'm reading I'm reading revelation 1:7
yes it says look he I'm getting an echo
here inside look he is coming with the
clouds and every eye will see him even
those who pierced him and all peoples on
the earth will mourn because of them so
shall it be right now my question is why
are the ones who pierced him who would
not be there who would be the unjust and
should be in the second resurrection why
are they there present at the first
resurrection all right well like that's
a great question I'm just going to put
you on a mute so you don't hear the echo
anymore and I'm gonna do my best to
answer that if you read in the book of
Matthew when Jesus is being condemned
the high priest challenges him and he
says I adjure you by God tell us whether
you are the Christ or not
and Jesus said here after you will see
the Son of man coming to the clouds of
heaven and so when Jesus comes there is
a special resurrection and where and by
the way that is in Matthew chapter 26
verse 64 jesus said to high priests it
is as you say nevertheless I say to you
hereafter you will see the Son of man
sitting at the right hand of power
coming in the clouds of heaven now when
it says they also that pierced him you
know it maybe some of the Roman soldiers
that were involved in the crucifixion of
course Jesus prayed for their
forgiveness the Roman centurion he may
be converted because he said truly this
was the son of God but probably not all
of those engaged in crucifying him so
the people who were really in first hand
responsibility for crucifying him
they're going to be specially raised
when he comes let me give you one more
verse if you look in Daniel chapter 12
and it tells you there in the first
first couple of verses of Daniel chapter
12 speaking of the return of Jesus it
says at that time Michael will stand up
the Great Prince that stands watch over
the sons your people and there'll be a
time of trouble and says many of those
who sleep in the dust of the earth will
awake this is verse to some to
everlasting life and some to shame and
everlasting contempt so those who were
engaged in the crucifixion and
condemnation of Jesus like the high
priests and maybe some of those that
involved in crucifying him they're gonna
see him they'll be raised and see him
coming to the world then they'll die
again and there'll be you know raised
again for judgment at the end of the
1,000 years so there are a few
exceptions you know the Bible says it's
appointed unto man wants to die well
you've got a few people that were like a
Enoch and Elijah that didn't die there's
a couple of exceptions the general
resurrection takes place when Jesus
comes
but when Christ died the Bible says many
of the graves graves in Jerusalem open
there was you know a few exceptions to
that and it tells you about those
exceptions Bible tells us Moses was
resurrected in the book of Jude chapter
verse 9 I should say
so hopefully that I'm gonna put you back
on Jerry did that make sense yes well
praise the Lord and and you know we do
have that lesson I mentioned to the
previous caller about the The Lord's
return and I think that you'll you'd
find that encouraging it tells about the
sequence that you find in the second
coming and it's called rescue from above
and I think you'll enjoy that alright
hey god bless you and thank you again
for your call talking next I think with
Chris who's calling from Florida Chris
you're on the air with Bible answers
live yeah yes Bosco God hi
can you hear me I can hear you loud and
clear yes thank you very much how can we
help you tonight it's going to be a very
general question about Zachariah and aim
of prophesies
I don't know what why I'm hearing the
echo I don't know either but anyway go
ahead and state your question yes the
Cariah when it talks about rebuilding
Jerusalem in chapter 14 and 13 yes
it all those things are going to happen
before the second coming of to you right
no some of those things are gonna happen
and you're talking about when it says
all the nations will gather against
Jerusalem yeah yeah and the city will be
taken in the houses rifled yet Zacharias
some of the prophecies in the Bible and
and again I'm gonna put you on hold here
just so that you don't hear the echo
some of these prophecies that you find
in the Bible have dual applications for
one thing it is true that you know
Jerusalem did come I'm sorry the Romans
did come against Jerusalem and they
destroyed the city and they mistreated
the women and they went into captivity
but there was a remnant the church was
saved that we're not cut off when the
Lord comes again at the end of the 1,000
years it says that gog and magog
that's all nations they gather against
Jerusalem they try to destroy but it
says the Lord will go forth and fight
for them that's verse 3 and so all of
these prophecies will be fulfilled but
please keep in mind when you're reading
some of these prophecies including
revelation as well as the Old Testament
prophecies they are not written in a
chronological sequential progressive
order the prophecies are given sometimes
in sound bites and we know that because
of the way that Matthew and the other
Gospel writers interpret the prophecies
about Jesus like the prophecy that said
a virgin will conceive and bear a son
and you'll call his name Emmanuel that
those verses there are obviously talking
about Jesus you read the verse before
and it's talking about Isaiah making a
prophecy to King Emma's about the nation
of Israel attacking from the north and
so in the midst of many of these
prophecies there were brief prophecies
so you read in Isaiah 14 it talks about
a prophecy to the king of tyre and the
next thing you know it's talking about
the fall of Lucifer and then it jumps
back to the king of tyre so in Ezekiel
does that with
so the you you've got to be careful not
to just read it all sequentially but
everything it says not a word of the
Lord is going to fall to the ground of
everything that the prophets have said
now hopefully that helps a little bit
did were you able to hear that Chris and
putting you back on and I want a really
good question yeah in his a book of a
minute it says about it talks about
drought for God's Word
yeah Amos chapter 8 the days are coming
when God says there'll be a famine in
the land but so is it going so happen
this or a second come and coming of
Jesus yes that's happening now that
prophecies I think being fulfilled now I
mean you got people all over the country
that have Bibles they get you know some
people are get five Bibles in their
house they never pick it up and read it
yeah and so you can have Bibles and the
other thing a famine for the Word of God
is not talking about there being a
shortage of Bibles it's talking about a
shortage oh the word so a lot of pastors
are teaching some really strange things
you probably heard you know pastors get
up and tell everybody God wants them all
to be millionaires and that's certainly
not the message of Jesus and so there's
a famine for the Word of God in the
world and I I see that happening in
different countries right now so well
thank you thank you very much Busta
absolutely appreciate your call Chris
thank you and with that we're gonna talk
to bill next calling from Chicago
Illinois bill you're on the air with
Bible answers live i pastor Doug how are
you doing good great are you hearing an
echo also ah slightly okay and your
question tonight I'm hoping I'm hoping I
don't get cut off because I don't have
radio to hear the answer okay well I'll
keep you on do my best
I my question is comes from second
chronicles chapter 18
okay it says um that God asks who will
go down and make a half arm fall at I
believe Mikayla okay this Bernie and
ramoth-gilead and a spirit a spirit
stands up and says I'll go down and make
them fall yes and the Lord says how will
you do that I'll be a lying spirit in
the mouth of his prophets yes now my
question is is the ten commandments for
just mankind or for lay everyone in
heaven - because it makes you sound like
it's okay for the spirit to lie yeah no
of course the Ten Commandments are is
their eternal principles of God and the
Bible says that God doesn't tempt any
man when talks about a spirit going and
causing a ham to fall
keep in mind my kaya is sharing a
parable my kaya the prophet of God is
standing before King Jehoshaphat and
King Ahab and all these false prophets
of BHEL are going and telling Ahab and
Jehoshaphat go fight against the Syrians
at ramoth-gilead you will win fight
fight fight and my kinda the prophet
gets up and he kind of tells his parable
he says aw there's a lying spirit in the
mouth of your prophets and he creates
this picture of God in heaven and God is
saying you know I'm gonna punish a.m.
God had already said through the
prophets that a hammer was gonna fall
because of his sins and that was one win
he'll I just said that when Ahab killed
Namath and then it shows he's you know
how this is gonna happen
it says there'll be a lying spirit now
do you remember the story of job where
the devil came before the Lord and the
devil went forth from the Lord and began
to afflict job you know that story yes
God did not want to afflict job but
sometimes the Lord allows certain things
and the Bible says in the New Testament
if you receive not a love of the truth
then God will
allow strong delusion that you should
believe a lie
okay and Paul when he says that he's
saying look when they have rejected the
prophets of God he said alright I'm
gonna let false prophets deceive him
so Mike ayah says there's a lying spirit
see God's trying to save a B he's giving
him one last chance he said these
prophets are lying to you
you're gonna go to battle and die and
they have still would not listen he
thought well I'll just all hide on the
outskirts of the battle and I'll put on
the armor and pretend manaan a soldier
and Bible says a stray arrow struck him
in the joints of the armor hit a vital
artery and he bled to death
so no God doesn't approve of lying Mike
I the Prophet is just saying evil
spirits were allowed to deceive Ahab
because they have did not listen to
God's Spirit I got it no yeah it's a
good question though I and I appreciate
your asking that hey thank you ball a
bill I'm gonna sign off I knew I had to
be missing something yeah well we're all
I'm still learning too so don't feel bad
you take care all right okay now to
Peter in New Jersey Peter you're on the
air with Bible answers live no pastored
hi thank you for the help booth tight
Emily or other words fabulous in fact
it's great well thank you in your
question I want to say ask about
election okay
there are certain verses in the Bible
that who like contradict each other
again a book of that a verses that say
those who were a appointed eternal life
it was like any that says we were dead
as passes and I've made us alive
harmonize those with whoever will knows
other verse yeah so you want to know
what does the Bible mean by election it
seems like you know part of the Bible it
seems like God is predestined and the
other part of the Bible it seems like we
get to choose right
yes sir exactly well you're asking one
of the biggest questions that
theologians have grappled with for about
2,000 years actually going back to going
back to the beginning is how much
freedom does man have we know God is
all-powerful but does God make things
happen you look in the Bible and God
says to Jeremiah have appointed you to
be a prophet from your mother's womb and
John the Baptist appointed a profit from
his mother's womb and yet then the Bible
says you know whosoever will let him
take the water of life and you know
Joshua says who is on the Lord's side
and so there's a lot of places in the
Bible that makes it clear that God God's
will is not always done in fact in the
Lord's Prayer when you say thy will be
done on earth as it is in heaven
the reason we say that is because God's
will is not always done if God's will is
always done we don't need to pray it so
people do have a free choice because if
everybody is predestined to be saved or
lost based on their choice of their own
then why would God punish the Lost if
they have no choice see what I'm saying
otherwise he becomes an accessory to the
sin God's basically that would be like
saying our God made some people to be
holy and he's gonna save them and he
made some other people and they can't no
matter what he's not gonna allow them to
be saved because he's pre elected them
to be sinners and it's like God's
created them defective and then he's
gonna punish him for being defective you
see what I'm saying
pastor yeah it's I wanted ESPA
theologian that question and he said
it's just a blessing that any one person
becomes saved God didn't be obligated to
say well that's true yeah what I mean by
that is it is the mercy of God we've
also
and we all deserve destruction we praise
the Lord that he has intervened in our
lives to save us but God is not wanting
to just save a few and here's some
verses the Bible says God is not willing
that any should perish 2nd Peter chapter
3 he doesn't want any to perish so if
some are perishing it must be because
they're making a choice and then again
the Bible says whoever if you're willing
and obedient Isaiah chapter 1 you will
eat the good of the land if we're
willing and so the reason we can love
God is because we have a free will if we
are pre-programmed to love God it stops
being loved we're just an automated
robot so I saw an interesting special
today on artificial intelligence and how
some people are falling in love with
their computers and I thought well how
can you do that a computer's just
programmed to say what it says it's not
thinking on its own volition so hey I
thank you very much for your question
we're gonna need to take a break here in
just a moment Peter and I hope hope we
got some resolution there I do have a
book you can look at online it's can a
saved man be lost go to the amazing
facts website anyone out there if you
want to understand the subject of
freewill predestination election go to
amazing facts and look at can a saved
man be lost
don't go away we're coming back in just
a moment
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with a Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website at amazing facts dot o-r-g
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love than
what went wrong
if you've missed any of our amazing
facts programs visit our website at
amazing facts org there you'll find an
archive of all our television and radio
programs including amazing facts
presents one location so many
possibilities amazing facts org every
bible question you have answered moves
you one step closer to the fullness of
god's will for your life so what are you
waiting for get the answers you need for
a fuller richer more confident life
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
pastor john ross is off for the night
and so with the help of our studio
volunteers we're gonna do our best to
get right back to your phone calls and
going next to talk to Marco calling from
Bakersfield California
Marco you're on the air with Bible
answers live yes hi attached to Doug hi
thank you for calling you're welcome
my question is more of a church history
question more than a Bible question okay
but every time I've asked a question I'm
not satisfied with the answers so maybe
you could help me I'll do my best my
question is what happened to the
Christians the Christian Church the one
that the book of Acts talks about that
they were first called Christians
in Antioch what happened to them after
the persecution after they were
dispersed and all the way up to after
the Reformation because the answer is
I've been getting even in a church
history class that I've taken is that
the Catholic Church is the Christian
Church well I think everybody knows all
let me do my best to give you you know
it's hard for me in three minutes we try
to budget about three minutes for our
questions and answers for each person
it's hard to cover you know 1700 years
in three minutes but I'll give you a
quick overview of what happened with the
conversion of Constantine you know up
until the time of Constantine Christians
were persecuted they were very faithful
they're very godly but about the time of
the conversion of Constantine a lot of
compromise came into the church that's
sort of evolved with a church now
instead of being underground enrollment
being persecuted they sort of became the
dominant power in Rome and Christianity
became the main religion Constantine's
mother claimed to be a Christian and
gradually the Romans commingled
Christianity some of them with the Roman
religion and he ended up with some of
the rites and ceremonies you find in the
the Roman Catholic Church well true
Christianity never did stop existing
during that time some of it went
underground you can read in Revelation
chapter 12 it says the woman fled into
the wilderness in a place where God is
prepared for that she should be
nourished there for three-and-a-half
prophetic years it calls it forty-two
months or a time at times in the
dividing of time that adds up to 1260
days a day in prophecies a year it's
1260 years from about 538 to 1798 when
Napoleon took the the Pope basically
captive and and the the church lost its
political sway it was badly wounded over
Europe well same time as the Reformation
it's that the beasts received a deadly
wound from the sword it's the Word of
God so the church never stopped existing
it kind of went
underground Bible says it fled into the
wilderness and was fed there that it
prophesied through sackcloth that means
it the work of the church was hindered
and obscured but it was still there so I
hope that helps a little bit and you
know we do have a study guide that talks
about it and it talks about this time
period that you're talking about I
really hope you'll look at it it's
called clothed with light and if you go
to the amazing facts website you can
either call our resource number and get
a free copy of that or you can download
it and read it right there online
actually I gave you the wrong name we've
we updated some of our lessons it's
called the Bride of Christ it's got a
new artwork the Bride of Christ and
illustrated lesson talks about the
history of the church during the dark
ages and I hope that helps a little
Marco thank you for your question again
talk next to Karen in Largo Florida
Karen you're on the air with empathy I
have struggled all my life and I feel I
will be lost
wakie do you feel like you just don't
love people enough or you're not able to
feel what they feel and just have that
kind of compassion yeah yes I don't feel
what they feel well I mean like I do
with animals but not humans huh you know
I'm not very good at doing psychology
but I know my guess would be that you've
a couple times growing up or in your
life with your family you've been let
down a few times and so you can you can
kind of close to yourself in a shell a
little bit but I have I have a mother
that was godly yeah
but a dad that wasn't well sometimes
people are afraid to invest emotionally
and other people because you're risking
getting hurt but yeah I pray that prayer
don't feel bad I I look at how much
Jesus loved people I'd say Lord I don't
love people very much compared to you
and you look at how the disciples laid
their lives down I said lord I must not
love people like they did and you know
what the answer is I say Lord give me
more love for people and he is he does
that so you know pray that say Lord give
me your spirit I wonder that so as the
Lord gives you a new heart
you know the Bible says he takes our
stony heart away and he gives us a heart
of flesh and that basically saying that
he'll help us to love people more and
God can definitely do that you know he
can take his we're a little bit
hard-hearted and we don't have the love
for others and when you get the new
heart you start feeling more compassion
more love for others and yeah I hope
that you'll you look at that you know
there's a book that we can give you for
free and it's called riches of His grace
it talks about the love of God and I
think you'll find that encouraging you
can just call 808 three five six seven
four seven ask for the book riches of
His grace or you can read it at the
amazing facts website brand new website
friends oh by the way you know I've been
meaning to tell everybody not only does
amazing facts have a brand new updated
it's a fancy-schmancy website it looks
really good now but we have a new app
that's out and so whether you've got the
Android or the Google platform brand new
app state-of-the-art amazing facts if
you want to get the app you go to the
you know Apple Store the Google store
and type in amazing facts ministry
amazing facts ministry and you can
download our new app there thank you for
your call Karen talking next to James in
Vero Beach Florida wonderful waves came
up in Vero Beach from Florence the
hurricane you there James hey Pastor Dan
so having me on your show again hi how
are you doing I'm doing just fine no no
effects from the hurricane you know
we're blessed didn't know if your waves
got bigger yeah and your question yes my
question is a general question
pertaining to prayer in general
specifically when it comes to a person
playing for something versus a group of
people playing for this
the Bible talks plenty about anybody
being able to come to the Lord in prayer
in your secret pray in the secret place
and speak to the Lord and you don't go
hear your prayer to use an example you
can take somebody that's a serious
problem and they can pray about it and
answer it on the other hand you could
have someone that has the same problem
and they
go around to all the friends and family
and they can and they ask for a lot of
people to pray for it is if the more
people that pray for it the more likely
it's going to be listened to by God so
my question is does it really matter
that much to God the more people that
pray for something because I can't
imagine gang-like being like okay my
minimum McCulloh 50 people have been
putting on that's a great question
that's a great question well first of
all you can read in the book of James
the effective fervent prayer of a
righteous man avails much so one person
when they are praying effectively and
fervently the prayer of one person look
at Elijah he prays and fire comes down
from heaven he prays again and rain
comes down after three and a half years
of famine so we there's no doubt that
one person's prayer can you know move
heaven but at the same time you do read
a lot of place in the Bible where it
talks about collective prayer so is
there more value in collective prayer
and you know I see I think that God is
more inclined sometimes to move when his
people come together and unite jesus
said if any two of you agree concerning
anything on earth and then you know the
part of the is it's second Chronicles
7:14 if my people which are called by my
name will humble themselves and pray so
it seems like when people join together
and collectively pray and collectively
repent if there is a problem that is
coming on a group then God's more
inclined to hear it seems when someone's
sick
they say James doesn't say and this is
James chapter 5 call for an elder it
says call for the elders to come and to
pray over them and so it does seem that
when people unite in prayer that it
implements the one high site 8 to say
this I believe it's biblical what I just
shared with you but I know that there's
one sister anything she wants she
doesn't tell just the Lord she tells 12
people to pray for that and so she
always believes that there's more power
in many people so she's giving everybody
her personal prayer list all the time
and I don't think that's what God wants
us to do because she figures because it
seems to be more value in multiple
prayers I'm gonna have everybody praying
for my list you see what I'm saying
right yeah so but you know I can't deny
the scriptures that seem to say they're
seen it seems to be some amplification
or additional value in many praying I
can think of another example in a lot of
the epistles or Paul specifically is
writing to his church into these tunes
and he keeps them in there in his
prayers yeah and when I read something
like that I think it sounds like these
people aren't really maybe praying so
well for themselves so it's like when
someone has to so that's when Paul
mentions that he keeps them in his
prayers yeah well every person's prayer
is a great value to God and but I do
think there's additional value you know
when church has come together for a
prayer meeting I think God when two or
three come together in a special way I
think that he's there in like I said in
some kind of increased way and now you
know I have a book I'll send you a free
copy that I wrote on the subject of
prayer and it's called teach us to pray
so you know the disciples went to Jesus
at Lord teach us to pray as John told
his disciples and and I go into that
principle so I'll send you a free copy
of that you can call 883 five six seven
four seven also anyone if you need
prayer we have chaplains standing by 808
three five six seven four seven for the
book teach us to pray or you can
download it at a
amazing facts dot o-r-g thank you very
much for your call James gonna move on
talk with Sharon calling from Kentucky
Sharon are you there yes hi I was
talking about Kentucky and my amazing
fact tonight
no I you may have your radio on in the
background because I think I'm hearing
myself I'm gonna turn it off right now
see there we go
and your question tonight mine refers to
about thinning I've heard people in the
church I'm not sure this will all don't
hang on speaker okay I've heard people
in the church say if you snooze all your
going to go to hell well my concern is
there's not a day that doesn't go by
that I don't have a thought come in my
mind that I should not have and I know
you know Satan will good pops in there
he put thought he tried by thoughts in
Jesus mind but Jesus was that pen but I
just feel like every day I have sinned
and according to what I understand them
to say with that you're perfectly not
mean you will not go to heaven all right
now that concerns me for me and for
anyone else who might be within earshot
inside the church by the church is like
right well what you know just hope
you're wondering about it do I have to
be perfect yeah is that the question
yeah first I know the Bible says there's
none perfect no not once
all right well there's two things the
Bible is talking about when it talks
about sin first of all everybody has
sinned that's past tense all have sinned
and fallen short of the glory of God and
I think we all agree that Jesus may
angel said to Mary you'll call his name
Jesus for he will save his people from
their sins and the first thing Jesus
says is repent and for the Kingdom of
Heaven repent what sin and that's a
sorrow for sin and turning away from it
but as you mentioned we have fallen
natures and so there's just all kinds of
sin
things that go through our minds and we
get tempted all the time in little areas
I think in the Bible Paul tells us in
Romans sin shall not have dominion over
you before you come to Jesus we're just
dominated by sin we are enslaved by sin
there's habits and behaviors that are
just dragging us down Jesus breaks those
chains so sin no longer has dominion it
doesn't mean you're never going to sin
because the Bible says in many things we
often offend and you know John says if
any man says I do not sin then the truth
does not abide in him so we all you know
we all struggle with the lower nature
but for the Christian whenever you
realize that you've got the wrong kind
of thoughts in your mind the Holy Spirit
convicts you of that and you immediately
turn from it
but if a Christian is still captive to a
life of sin that's different you see
what I'm saying are you still there
Sharon may have turned or volume to hell
you know Sharon I've got a book let me
just see here Sharon are you still able
to hear me yeah okay where did you hear
my answer yes I did okay you know I've
got a book and it talks about is it
possible to live without sinning and it
really answers your question I've even
got a I've got a sermon that I do that's
called the perfect Christian and I think
it helps explain this balance but I'll
send you a free copy of that book is it
possible to live without sinning I think
you're gonna find encouragement in that
and the number is 883 five six seven
four seven you call that number to give
them your address I'll send you the book
or go to the amazing facts website you
can download it read it right there
online or you can download the PDF and
read it on your device whenever you're
inclined so thank you very much you're
absolutely welcome that's a very
important question people often wonder
about talking neck - next to Chris
calling from Wilmington Delaware Chris
you're on the air with Bible answers
live hi hi I had a question of
drinking alcohol so I believe that
drinking alcohol is a sin I'm very
familiar with the different scriptures
that talk about that yeah the one
Scripture I'm not really able to get a
handle on is in numbers 28 7 where it
talks about strong wine importing to the
Lord for a drink offering yes and so my
question is if alcoholic beverages are
used in an offering to God is alcohol
always a sin or is it just drunk enough
well I believe that Christians should
not drink any alcohol alcohol or just
for one second just look at it this way
alcohol is a drug it is the most deadly
drug in the world I think the only thing
that kills more people than alcohol is
mosquitoes with malaria alcohol most of
the car accidents on the road you just
ask any highway patrolman most of the
calls police get for family abuse
alcohols involved most of the people in
prison are there because of alcohol
birth defects accidents in the hospital
I mean it is amazing how much misery in
our society is called by caused by it's
a drug alcohol is a drug even though
they legalize it and they tax it it is
an addictive drug a very addictive drug
I think one out of five or six people
that drink becomes a problem drinker an
alcoholic so when the Bible says wine is
a mocker strong drink is raging
we know that's talking about alcoholic
they had two kinds of strong drink in
the Bible one strong drink wasn't
alcoholic at all the word strong means
concentrated they used to dehydrate
their grape juice and make it into a
pace so they could transport large
amounts it was much lighter they then
add the water rehydrated and they drink
it it wasn't new wine it wasn't fresh it
wasn't the best but it's kind of like
concentrate aren't uses never as good as
as you know freshen orange juice so when
it says in numbers and there's another
verse in Deuteronomy 14 it's a strong
drink it doesn't mean always alcoholic
it means that they would have this pace
that they would reconstitute and they've
actually you know discovered a number of
shipwrecks in and archaeological work
where they found these are cisterns and
these urns that were filled with this
grape juice paste or concentrate
sometimes it was dehydrated so it was
very sweet and it's like raisins raisins
keep a long time because they're kind of
dehydrated grapes they don't ferment so
they have this strong grape juice that
was concentrate and then there's also
strong drink that was alcoholic he just
read the context when it says that Noah
drank wine and walked around naked while
he was drunk it's pretty clear there but
Jesus speaking of the sacrifice he says
concerning the Lord's Supper he says I
will not drink this wine until I drink
it with you again new in the father's
Kingdom the grape juice at the for
religious purposes was to be new wine
unfermented all right I hope that helps
a little bit Chris all right and you
know you've seen my book I'm assuming on
wine alcohol in the Christian you there
Chris yeah I've seen it yeah well if you
of course you can for anyone out there
that has questions on that you can
download the book alcohol in the
Christian and you will send your FREE
copy you can download it and it sounds
like you've read that Chris I hope that
makes sense and that helps a little bit
it does thank you you're welcome
appreciate your call talking to is a
Linnell a-- in texas
lonoa you're on the air with Bible
answers live yes hi my question is on
the subject of tithing okay um like for
example if my 10% came out to a hundred
bi-weekly and so that would total out
for two hundred a month what would I be
allowed to pay that all at once in the
beginning or the ending of the month or
am I supposed to do that like every
Sabbath as on the you know on them on
the
we get week I get paid or what's the
proper yeah
I don't think God is a cruel I don't
think God is a cruel taskmaster it's a
good principle that while you're
thinking about it you do it you know the
Bible talks about giving the firstfruits
to the Lord not your last fruits I you
know I know some people they say well I
pay my tithe that once a year at the end
of the year and you know bless their
hearts but what if they die before that
years over it so you don't want to you
know you don't want to put off you don't
want to have the Lord last on your list
and so it's not a bad idea to you know
do it whenever you get your check your
paycheck just kind of take it off the
top so you're not tempted and you just
sayin Lord you're first in my life
I know pastor Ross here is an amazing
story about a lady in Africa whenever
they took up the offering she always put
in brand-new bills and they said why are
you always putting in brand new bills
she says well when I get paid I go to
the bank and ask for new bills because I
am NOT gonna give old bills to the Lord
I want to give the best to him and I
don't think God's asking us to all do
that but it was sort of a sweet story if
you you know if you say all right Lord
I'm gonna do it once a month God's gonna
bless you but since these are blessing
and paint eyes do you want to postpone
that blessing that you want to get it
soon see what I'm saying you the aerelon
ol Anela
yeah okay yeah yeah you know I have a
study guide that we can send you on that
subject that talks about tithe and it's
free or you can read it online it's
called In God We Trust
of course that's printed on all the
money in god we trust' and call the
resource line eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and we'll send
you a free copy or you can go to the
website amazing facts dot o-r-g and do
it that way um all right mark calling
from our clear michigan mark i've got
like one minute for your question do you
have time to ask it quickly sure um I
know I know your testimony and it's very
inspiring and I know you've learned no
and eventually for that I baptized by
the Holy Spirit without being
necessarily ordained initially by a
religious organization now my question
is can anyone who believes in the Lord
to be baptized by another a believer who
has been baptized by the Holy Spirit but
not necessarily redeemed by a religious
organization but maybe part of like a
temple occurred for a house church right
unlike the early church it's a good
question
I do think you're gonna find in the
Bible that when the Holy Spirit was
poured out and like when the Holy Spirit
came on the people of Samaria they sent
for Peter and John to come up and to lay
hands on the people in baptize him they
evidently thought that there was some
Authority and Peter where Phillip didn't
do it right then now later Philip
baptizes I saw their situations like
Philips alone in the desert with the
Ethiopian eunuch and he says look
there's no one here here's water I'll
baptize you so I think there are
situations where if that's the only way
it can be done but if if everybody who
says I'm a Christian starts baptizing
it's like if everybody starts performing
marriages sometimes the couples don't
get marriage counseling they're not
carefully discipled before they're
baptized so most churches including our
church believe that it should be the
ordained ministers to do the baptizing
that have been sort of cleared and
trained to make sure the folks are
thoroughly baptized are thoroughly
discipled great question free study on
is baptism necessary we'll send you call
808 three five six seven four seven and
you can ask that study guide is baptism
really necessary you know listening
friends it wouldn't be fair to someone
else to take a call if we did not get to
your call this week then hope you give
us another chance and want to remind you
once again we have a brand new website
amazing facts dot o-r-g
take a look and then after you look at
it please share it with your friends you
know what if you click that you like the
amazing facts website on your Facebook
page it helps more people find it and it
helps spread the gospel what an easy way
to do evangelism just click that you
like it and keep in mind when you email
us we're only here because you
helps keep us on the air thank you so
much until next week god bless thank you
for listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
does your heart burns for a better
purpose do you yearn to do more with
your faith do you desire to be a
powerful witness a blaze for Jesus
Christ where do you start make your
first step at eff go the amazing fact
center of evangelism here at Affco i've
learned so many things in my spiritual
growth has just skyrocketed
asko has distilled fifty years of
amazing facts evangelistic expertise
into a dynamic professional and
educational experience that transforms
the nervous christian into a prepared
and bold witness Affco is really about
learning while doing it's a
one-of-a-kind experience for those who
are serious about entering gospel
ministry and those who simply want to
make an impact in their local churches
and communities go to ask org today and
explore this life-changing program Affco
equipping soul-winners setting the world
ablaze for god deep within the pages of
the Bible stories of great heroes heroes
of great deeds great love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry shadows of light seeing Jesus
in all the Bible get your copy today by
calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at
[Music]